community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care
and silver state schools credit union
silver state schools credit union
continues to prioritize people over
profit providing its members with the
tools they need
to make smart financial decisions
[Music]
so unlike a bank being a silver state
schools credit union member
is unique because number one we're not
for profit
and so what that means is when you open
a savings account you actually have
shareholder benefits and member benefits
that you wouldn't have at a bank
such things as supporting our local
community
and actually funding our scholarship
program silver state schools credit
union helps members who want to learn
more about their managing their finances
by offering different financial literacy
resources
one of my favorites is money moves and
that's free online resource
uh financial education center that
offers interactive courses
to learn more about managing your
finances applying for your first credit
card
owning a home even buying a car all of
that is available at silverstatecu.com
money moves another great resource is
the balance programs one of my favorites
is something that i've i had at all the
credit unions that i've worked at
the balance program offers our members
free financial
guidance tools and live webinars
actually to teach them about financial
counseling
we also partner with our local schools
to introduce financial literacy to
students it teaches them to be smart
savers and also teaches them
about preparing for their financial
future so one of the things that we're
really proud about at silver state
schools credit union is almost anyone
can qualify to be a silver state schools
credit union member
the members of our education community
such as our teachers our administrators
our staff are all obviously eligible
but once you're a member you have and
you and your immediate family are also
eligible
one of the other great ways that you can
also become a member is if you make a
one-time donation to vegas pbs
you're actually eligible for membership
that gives you an opportunity to not
only support the
community at large but but also to gain
membership with us so you have premier
products and services
while also making a contribution to one
of our community partners
so again these are some of the things
that make silver state schools credit
union membership
great and it differentiates us from
being a banking customer